the multi-device experiences platform or
MDX is an extensible cloud AI service
hosted in Azure MDX enables research and
development on task focused scenarios
that span multiple devices empowering
first and third party developers to
build intelligent and interactive
experiences that capitalize on the
convenience efficiency and strengths of
multi device usage throughout a task the
MDX platform enabling research and
development in multi device experiences
check out how the power of MDX could
enhance even the simplest of daily tasks
Alexa a chef to show me that pee recipe
I looked at last night here is the
recipe for traditional paella Valenciana
all right let's cook
how much rice do I need 350 grams Paia
rice how many cups is that it is 1 in
3/4 cups I don't have green beans can I
replace the green beans or something
else yes you put you snap peas instead
add green beans to my grocery list I
have added green beans to your grocery
list
okay what's the next step
pour in about a liter of the chicken
stock
are there any wines that would pair well
with this recipe how about a chilled dry
residue from Navarra
[Music]
can you let me know when this step is
done I'll start a 10 minute timer for
you Thanks MDX
[Music]